joining me now to react as the host of
the Michael not--not show Michael
Knowles who wrote the book reasons to
vote for Democrats with absolutely zero
words on the page and went to number one
nice to see you Michael nice to see you
what do you make of all of this you can
buy a shower curtain how much is the
shower curtain shower curtain it says
support the 25th amendment it's $70 ok
this the sweater is attached it says I'm
Miss Barack $380 the Trump economy must
be doing pretty well
his opponents rich they can buy these
sweaters you know both sides of the
aisle produce merchandise but there's a
big difference the right-wing
merchandise generally comes from a place
of humor to use one example a book
called reasons to vote for Democrats and
it's blank or Trumpy bear or whatever
the left-wing merchandise comes from
this place of anger of raw emotion it
just says F Trump Kathy Griffin has a
whole line of products it says two words
one of them starts with an F the other
one says Trump it comes from anger it
comes from raw emotion I think what this
shows us how powerless the left feels
right now they can't be Trump at the
ballot box they can impeach him they
can't beat him with beta O'Rourke or
Andrew Gilliam or any of those so they
buy this schlock to express their anger
to show their virtue but this is
fundamentally hypocritical the left
tells us all the time they rarely
against wealth then they spent $380 on
and I miss Barack sweater they talk
about the environment global warming is
going to kill us all then they produce
cheap plastic schlock by the metric ton
all of which is going to end up in the
Pacific Ocean and then they tell us
Trump has to be civil and what do they
do they put four-letter words that begin
with F on all of their merchandise it's
a hilarious irony and they they just
keep buying it and you said Republicans
do this as well you just said the
difference is Republicans have more
humor with it we have a little bit more
humor that's right and you know by the
way the left is being defrauded that
they have the the pecan resist ice cream
from Ben & Jerry's they say they're
going to donate to left-wing causes
they're going to give $100,000 to
left-wing causes Ben and Jerry's sells
half a billion dollars worth of ice
cream every year they are defrauding
these guys all that the left is doing is
making rich millionaires capitalists
even richer I usually say pecan but in
this case you have to say pecan right do
the ready can resist they're even
messing up the pronunciation thank you
so much Michael for being with us good
to see